[Music]
thank you very much for joining us today
we couldn't imagine a better speaker for
this memorial lecture we have all sorts
of topics to discuss from your investing
career to your work on the environment
to your recent political activism before
we get there I wanted to start with your
time as a GSB student back when you were
in these seats metaphorically speaking
did did you ever imagine you would be on
this stage as a view from the top
speaker I can't say I was thinking this
far forward and I can't say I really
understood the significance when I was
going to stand for Business School at
the Stanford Business School in terms of
leadership in our society so I think I
have a different perspective than I the
importance of this institution now and
obviously I'm a lot older and have
poured I said I'm in wouldn't have time
for anything all right fair enough I
mean we're all facing the same types of
constraints here another question for
you what was your most influential class
at the GSB so I think I taste two
classes all equivocate one was
touchy-feely I don't know if they do
they still do interpersonal dynamics yes
look I love touchy feely because it was
a chance to see how people interact in a
much more honest way than when people
are normally very controlled and also
when I went home for Christmas break and
my father looking goes like is this a
class seriously so I loved that too just
annoying him but I also took a course
here in international economics that was
I thought absolutely brilliant in terms
of thinking about basically competitive
advantage on a national level and
thinking about what makes societies work
what makes societies product
of widest some societies move forward
really well and what are the reasons
that other societies have continuing
problems and I thought that was
something that I'd never looked at so
systematically it was really a brilliant
course speaking of making societies
productive let's now turn to your early
days as an investor you were a rising
star at Goldman when Wall Street was
booming and then in less than a year you
had moved to San Francisco to start up a
small merger arbitrage hedge fund what
gave you the confidence to make this
sudden change so let's be clear when I
moved back out here from Goldman first
of all my wife and I wanted to live west
of the Mississippi period so I knew that
Goldman Sachs was in New York and
therefore I was gonna have to leave it's
also true that I got in a gigantic fight
with the guy I was working for and
therefore I felt like under no
circumstances do I want to continue to
go to work and see that guy every
morning mm-hmm which is not a great
career move but also I felt like if
you're one of the things I love about
investing is you can measure the results
and I felt like if I do a bad job at
Goldman Sachs they're gonna fire me if I
do a bad job on my own I'm also gonna
get fired but if I do a good job on my
own I have much more upside than I do at
Goldman Sachs and so I didn't think I
was taking more risk because I felt like
either way if you don't do a good job in
life it doesn't work out so I was more
than willing to bet on myself in the
sense that if if you're taking that risk
anyway why not at least give yourself
the upside and have the opportunity to
go surfing on weekends it's helpful we
did want to live west of the Mississippi
you then went from 10 million dollars in
seed capital to managing about 20
billion dollars by the time you left
step down from Farallon in 2012 what
challenges did you face as the fund
scaled particularly those related to
leadership well
first of all one of the things that we
tried to do was to grow gradually
because I felt if you went from ten
million dollars to twenty million
dollars that wasn't a step function so
that you could change your team slowly
enough so that you continue to do the
job and that if you went from ten
million dollars to three hundred million
dollars you're in a completely different
business and you're taking a gigantic
risk with whether you have the
capability to actually perform that
function so we really grew very
consistently but we never grew
you know geometrically I will say this
when I think back to what we were doing
at Farallon and when I'm mad at myself I
think that there's a rule in
organizations that up to 125 people you
don't have to be that formally organized
and you know I remember being here in
the HP way management by walking around
that's really what I liked to do was
just talk to everybody and try and stay
up to date and hear what the problems
were and we had a very open office
physically so that there were no walls
there were no offices so that there was
a lot of internal communication whether
people wanted it or not I think above a
hundred and twenty-five people you start
to really need rules and you really need
hierarchy and you really need a way of
organizing people and we did do that but
if there's one thing that I would fault
myself for and I do get mad about it is
I think at some point we had a very very
flat organization and I really did feel
like we made decisions listening to
everybody very clearly and we didn't
really have a hierarchical
decision-making and if I were doing it
again I would be a little more insistent
that the people who'd proved themselves
into which I would throw my name should
get a little more decision-making than
some of the people who thought they knew
a heck of a lot and then it would be
like oh my gosh I had no idea that would
happen because I'm like well that's what
I was talking to you about for the last
six months and so I if there is when I
think back to the growth as you get more
larger you actually
have to be able to have some system
where the senior people really do have
to listen have to take into account but
ultimately you know they're supposed to
be in the position they're gonna get
hung if it doesn't turn out to be a good
decision so they should the younger
people should defer to them until they
get in that position as you were growing
consistently one thing that it was also
growing was farallon's investments in
the coal industry you know Farallon
became one of the major players in
sustaining and growing the coal industry
in Australia Indonesia and China knowing
what you know now in a different time
would you have made those investments
again no look I would say somewhere
around to ten years ago basically I was
sitting here thinking about what was
going to turn out to be a huge problem
and I started to really focus on climate
and then I started to look at all our
investments differently and so it really
was a situation where I felt like up
till then we were you know we invested
in every single industry including
fossil fuels which were probably less
than proportionate to what they are in
the whole worldwide economy or the
American economy but definitely
significant investments and starting
about ten years ago I realized wow this
is just going to be a gigantic problem
and I've got to not only stop doing this
but I've got to get out of this which I
did do and have done but I feel like do
I wish that I'd come to that conclusion
ten years or 20 of course I do
do I wish I were taller and playing
center in the NBA
yes I wish I were smarter and it figured
out sooner but I think that what we're
really coming from as a society is
exactly the same place which is this our
society was based around fossil fuel
energy that's just the truth we all
drive cars we've all grown up in a
society where electricity was largely
based on fossil fuels it's not a
question of that the question is what
are we going to do about it and how fast
can we move away from it and how fast do
we have to move away from it so of
course I wish
when my good friend Dan lash off was
writing his PhD thesis on climate change
in 1989 that I was like oh Dan's
absolutely right we should be really
careful about this but it took me longer
than you know obviously the sooner the
better
but it's but I feel like ten years ago I
came to that conclusion I decided this
is really important that this is a thing
which will be critical for our society
and critical for everybody on this
planet so therefore we can't equivocate
about it wish I'd been smarter could we
drill down on that moment a little bit
because I think there's there's a very
deep amount of thought that you put into
this particular issue and yet there's so
many issues out there in the world and
you've spoken about many of them you've
spoken about inequality and you've
spoken about tobacco and the harm things
suppose the society gone through many
different topics how is it the climate
resonated so deeply and specifically
what you saw at that time ten years ago
well let me give you my thinking Venn
which is this I mean I know the GSB has
a ton of foreign-born students but as an
American I felt like our system
basically works and that the way it
basically works is we're rude we're
Volger we're loud we disagree with each
other but if everybody's trying to solve
the problem regardless of where they're
coming from we compromise we solved the
problem we move on that and everyone
else is thinking they're very rude and
loud which is true but we compromise and
solve the problem and I looked at
climate and I thought my gosh we're not
solving the problem that we have this
huge problem that could be existential
for our society and for some reason the
normal American loud conflictual
compromise isn't happening here and I
felt like I really believed in our
system so I want to get into our system
more to try and figure out how I can be
part of its normal solution for big
problems for us and so when I that's I
have changed actually my understanding
as a result of getting
into that question and diving into that
problem specifically it's changed my
understanding of how America really
works but the reason I did that problem
was I thought it was existential and I
didn't understand why the normal
American Democratic ugly messy loud way
wasn't working in that case this gives
us a really good transition over to your
extensive philanthropic work you signed
on to the The Giving Pledge in 2010 and
you've been especially active in
environmental causes especially since
that moment that you described where you
were you saw the light so to speak how
did you go about finding the right
causes to back buy I mean it's such a
classic thing I think that you learn a
lot by doing and I think that what we
found over time is hopefully we're a lot
better at what we're doing as a result
of all the things that we did that
weren't so smart and you know to a large
extent I would say my understanding of
the idea of philanthropy is really
different from what I would say is a
traditional understanding and
philanthropy because actually what we've
tried to do is to set up operating
enterprises in the real world that are
hands-on to actually affect the kinds of
things we're hoping for that sounds
complicated but for instance we have a
community bank where the equity is
through a foundation so we can never get
the money back so in a way we've given
the money away forever and ever but it's
a bank that's FDIC insured it makes
loans to for economic justice
environmental sustainability women and
minority-owned businesses so it's got a
very specific social thrust done through
our capitalist economic system but with
a complete value driven agenda so it's
kind of you we really are we're not
giving money away to people we're
lending money we need them to pay us
back with interest
so we can make more loans to other
people so they can succeed and so that's
not I mean I've never heard of some
else doing that or thinking of that is
philanthropy in fact when we suggest
other people that it's a good idea they
look very askance but we really believe
in operating enterprises where people
are involved on it you know really in
the real world trying to have impact in
a big way and also to show that things
are possible
is that a strategy that underlies your
focus on both the Steyr Taylor Center
and the Tomcats Center here at Stanford
I mean you you you've clearly believed
that Stanford has a role to play in your
strategy and fighting climate change so
one of the things that's true if you
look at climate and you kind of divide
it into what is happening in the real
world in terms of the natural world
changes and what's happening in terms of
research and technology and capability
of dealing with the problems or solving
the problems and then our willingness to
actually solve the problems and use the
technology and the techniques we have I
felt as if and I still feel like I mean
I love Stanford Stanford has led
revolutions in technology I wanted
Stanford to use its broad range of
capabilities to be a leader in this on
every scale so you know from an
investment side a legal side a
technology side
I felt like Stanford has done this in IT
why shouldn't we be doing this in energy
we have you know they're very few places
that have the breadth of research the
sort of capability of across the board
making this difference and making it
happen and so you know part of the
solution to this is our ability to solve
it from a technical basis and then to
understand how that fits into society
and so since I love Stanford since I
knew the capabilities I felt like I
would really like it if Stanford leads
on this and if you actually look at what
Stanford did on renewing its own
electricity plant for the campus that
was I think design designated the best
engineering project in the United States
of America in 2015
the Stanford you know electricity system
so that we have the capability of doing
this in a way that is significant and
replicable and that's what I wanted to
see apparently we're also pretty good at
football
Wow
I'd go with before a fall it'll pass on
the message to David Shaw but before we
go to national politics I'd like us I'd
like to focus a bit on your activism
here in our own backyard in California
voter ballot initiatives allow the
public to vote directly on proposed laws
you have focused on these ballot
initiatives as a way to influence a wide
range of policies including climate and
energy legislation how did you arrive at
this particular approach so for the
people who aren't California citizens we
do have this extremely fat and
complicated ballot where you're
basically allowed to do direct democracy
so if you can get enough signatures
raised you can put a proposition on the
ballot that everybody gets to vote on
and if fifty point one percent of the
people vote for it you have a new law
and this has led to some truly heinous
outcomes and it's also led to some
really good outcomes and so the first
thing that we did was I co-chaired with
George Shultz
fighting a ballot initiative which was
designed to get rid of our progressive
energy legislation our cap-and-trade
system and a bunch of other things that
have to do with basically having the
most progressive energy laws in the
world that was in 2010 to oil companies
wanted to basically change those laws
and get rid of them and so we were in we
were the know on 23 campaign so why do
we did that because traditionally when
you get to the ballot and it's a
question of business versus
environmentalists jobs versus the
environment jobs and business always win
and that was the way people thought this
was going to happen and there had been a
previous ballot initiative in 2006 so
four years before where
an individual from LA spent 70 million
bucks and lost his initiative so there
was no one rushing to be the
environmental side of this proposition
so here's what it's like most of the
jobs I've had there was no one else
stupid enough to take it mm-hmm
but the difference was it actually was a
formative experience for me because it
really was about climate in some ways
but we had a rule no one can talk about
climate that the way that we're going to
talk to people is about local human
issues of jobs and clean air and in fact
by far the best TV commercial we had was
a commercial of a woman who was the head
in California of the American Lung
Association talking about clean air and
she it's the American Lung Association
so obviously cared about it she was very
credible
it's a lovely person came across
incredibly well and we got 70% of the
vote for people who said basically we
don't want to get rid of our you know
clean air / climate legislation we also
found and I I think it's it was
incredibly significant for me that we
wanted a different message which was
more jobs cleaner air but we also wanted
a completely different coalition so we
spent we knew that all the people who
are traditional environmentalists of
course would be on our side in terms of
groups you know the NRDC EDF League of
Conservation Voters Sierra Club of
course those people would be for us but
actually when you look at the people of
California the number one group who
supports everything environmental
everything about progressive energy
everything against climate change are
Latinos number two group
african-americans number three group
asian-americans so when we were looking
at the people of California for votes we
knew from the beginning we were going to
get progressive business and we
basically split the chambers of commerce
around the state we had at least half
this chambers on our side we had
organized labor but we went to every
community group and we wanted to make
sure that people understood it because
actually that's the
the people who are not necessarily
considered members of the Sierra Club
and might Bruns once tried to kill me
for saying this but people who haven't
necessarily been the what you'd think of
is the fabled environmentalists actually
are the environmentalist and that's how
we got seventy percent of the vote is we
look at a completely different slice of
Californians and we said our coalition
is much broader and our message is much
different and that is something that I
learned in that year and it was true
then and it's true now
so these campaigns that you've organized
on behalf of these causes are not cheap
California's you know already one of the
most expensive media markets in the
country and as these things go national
I mean the the costs grow almost
exponentially what would you say to
those who argue that spending massive
amounts of money on these types of
campaigns actually undermines our
democratic process there's no question
that the money in politics is completely
out of control and I would be strongly
in favor of changing the rules I
completely agree with that I do think
the money in politics is a cancer and
it's distorting and has led to some
terrible outcomes and continues to I
don't think there's you really can't
look at this tax bill that's going
through the Congress right now and not
see that that's exactly what's happening
that we have a fight between moneyed
interests and the people of the United
States and the people the United States
are losing badly no question about it
that happens to be the system we have so
I could say you know what I wish the
system were different until the system
is different I'm going to sit on the
sidelines or I could say I really think
it's important that we keep our clean
energy legislation I really think it's
important to close this tax loophole I
really think it's important to stop
young people from smoking and just suck
it up and spend the money or I could be
pure and say I'm going to keep the money
and I'm gonna you know wait until the
system is perfect which will be by the
way never so I do think
should change it I'm completely against
Citizens United decision I think it's an
absolutely terrible decision for
democracy I think it is distorting the
way our societies run and I'm completely
committed to a change to what I would
think of if you look at what we do
I believe the solution to our problems
is broader democracy and broader
participation and more power to the
people of the United States so if you
look at what our organization does we're
a grassroots organization last year we
with our partners we knocked on 12 and a
half million doors we were on 370
college campuses we registered eight
hundred and seven thousand people in the
state of California about 350 thousand
people outside every one of those was an
attempt to get people or
underrepresented to part to be RIT to be
registered engaged and to participate so
because unless you're doing that your
voice isn't heard and you're not going
to get a fair shake so everything we're
doing is about broader democracy more
participation by people who are
underrepresented so that they'll get a
fair shake in our democracy and the
money side of this on the other side is
huge and absolutely contrary to every
single thing we're doing and in fact
they're fighting their head off to try
and prevent Americans from being able to
exercise their franchise and to
participate for so I'm hearing you say
something very interesting which is that
you know even even if Gandhi once said
you know an eye for an eye will make the
world blind you're essentially telling
us well in this case two wrongs do make
a right that if you want to fight you
have to fight the fight with with with
your own with you know whatever you've
got on in your arsenal oh no no no no no
I will not accept that question I am NOT
jabbing anyone's eye out that is
absolutely unfair what I believe what
they are doing is anti-democratic and I
believe the only thing I'm doing is to
try and make the democracy broader more
complete and more just I don't think
this is an eye for an eye I don't think
I'm doing anything that is not
absolutely positive and in favor of the
American system in the American people
I'm not doing anything to hurt them all
trying to do is have a counterbalance
that is supporting the people of the
United States this isn't an eye for an
eye this is completely different this is
an attempt to protect a system that was
set up over 200 years ago where the idea
is everybody is equal not every dollar
is equal but every person is equal so
and I happen by the way to support a lot
of the causes you back so understand
this comes from a really good place
George just me I just agree with you I
intend to I think it would be edifying
for people understand something which is
you know you've build yourself
occasionally as the left's answer to the
Koch brothers never not one time thank
you for saying it not once and never
will I've someone else I promise it's
never happened
are there people ask me if I'm the left
answer to the Koch brothers and I always
say no all right well well challenge
accepted I guess what what what I've
been there every time no III III III
agree that it's not a fair
characterization to compare people like
that but I think one one thing that I
was curious to understand is what do you
think the American left or rather just
progressive causes in general and those
who back them could learn from the Koch
brothers well say this I mean I don't
know if you've got have you guys read
dark money there's a book about the Koch
brothers essentially kind of going back
through their family history about what
they've done from an economic basis and
what they've done on a political basis
and they've been really consistent they
have been pushing on this stuff really
for over a century as a family and so I
admire the fact that they have continued
to push on the things that they care
about over a very long period of time
and when you've said that you've said
every single thing that I appreciate
about them
we're talking about what can what can we
learn from them yeah we don't have to
appreciate them be consistent you can
system trying is you know I think that
there's no question that over the you
know our organization I quit my job five
years ago at an organization has been up
for approximately five years we're much
better today than we were five years ago
what we can do in terms of going
door-to-door what we can do on college
campuses what we can our capability of
making change is much better because of
the five years that we've spent you know
improving ourselves I mean when we I
thought at Farallon and I think today
when you look at when I look back at
2017 I'll say what did we do in 2017 did
it work didn't it work I will also ask
is our organization stronger at the end
of the year than it is at the beginning
of the year because there are lots of
things you can do that makes a year be
good at the expense of a long term
growth of your organization capability
and I always feel like you want to have
good results and you want to grow your
capability and so when I think about
what we're trying to do and what I think
progressives should be trying to do is
be aware of that second part the you
know it's a long-term proposition to get
this country back on a trajectory of
growth and justice and so any one year
any one election is not going to do it
you've always got to be building
capability over time so speaking about
building capability I think it's it's
probably a time just to change topics
slightly it's a one that's been in the
news recently I believe I've seen a
commercial or two regarding your love of
President Trump if if Trump invited you
to work on climate change policy at the
White House would you accept no there's
there's absolutely no chance that the
president has any interest in seriously
working on climate policy
every single thing he's done in the
election and substance sub subsequent to
the election has been to work against us
having progressive objectively derived
energy policies so there is no chance
that he would make a good-faith effort
to have me come and try and come up with
a program so that as a country we could
move forward in a positive way and I
think that the fact that I'm saying that
I deeply regret you know I I started by
saying my belief in the American system
is as long as you cede to the other
person that they're patriotic that their
first goal is to help the American
people and that they're driven by a
belief in data objectivity and analysis
that's the American system and if people
disagree with you fine of course they do
I mean anyone who's arrogant enough to
think they're always right is really
ridiculous so the American system is we
may disagree but as long as you cede
good intentions then we can work
together and compromise in the middle
and probably come out with something
better than either party had at the
start of the conversation that's my
basic belief I don't believe for a
second that those are the circumstances
under which that proposal would be made
and therefore I wouldn't do it so in
talking about growing the capability of
your organization how would you say this
particular campaign to impeach President
Trump grows the capability of your
organization over the long term so what
we're actually doing which I encourage
you to sign on to please WWE to impeach
calm is trying to give the American
people directly a voice in this
conversation and I think it's fair to
say that the Republicans in Washington
DC don't like it and the Democrats in
Washington DC also don't like it but the
fact of the matter is we have the
technology for the American people to
act
independently and to speak up and the
voice of the American people in a
democracy is supposed to be dispositive
and so what we're trying to do is give
Americans an easy way together to raise
their voice because we believe that
we're actually in danger that every
single day the health and safety of
American citizens is it danger and that
we can't sit by and pretend it's not
happening and so when I think about this
campaign I think about it the same way
you ask me the questions about the
propositions the propositions are there
for when the government in Sacramento
fails to be able for the people of
California to be able to enact laws
together and what we're doing with this
impeachment petition is to try and give
the American people a chance to do just
that even though we can't make laws we
can in effect raise our voice and change
the conversation and say there is
something desperately wrong here in the
United States this is not a partisan
appeal this is not to Democrats or
independents or Republicans this is to
everybody who's worried about the United
States of America and that is what we
are trying to do I had a look for the
privacy policy on the impeachment
campaign and one of the things that says
is that you know the information you
provide can be used for essentially
future outreach is that another
objective of this campaign is that yes
maybe maybe this campaign raises
awareness of some issues but does it
also provide a platform for a really
devoted set of followers to be reached
out to over the course of your next
objectives well I do I would love it if
we can get a way for the American people
to have their voice be heard over a long
period of time and also to provide a
place for to basically put out content
so as far as I'm concerned look we have
seen information technology change the
way people relate in so many different
ways and the capability of Americans
we've seen this all over the world I
mean we have seen politics
turned upside down by the ability of
citizens around the world to communicate
real-time and it's not and we've seen it
here too in the election process the
question is is there a way for Americans
to come together in a way so that we can
actually have our voice be heard when
there's something desperately wrong
that's what we're trying to do thank you
so much one more question before we turn
it over to the audience for Q&A I wanted
us to focus back on on the GSB student
body for a second and ask you if you
could be a GSB student again and and
would be very fortunate to have you
annum or hurt student body and I wanted
to help the environment where would you
go right now and why as a job yes for a
career well I'll say this I don't think
there's one answer to that question you
know I I have four kids who are 23 25 27
and 29 and they are I think that they're
generations so for everybody who's
sitting here who's in those that age
range I think that that your generation
actually is much more thoughtful about
the way that you're thinking about your
careers and your lives
in the class of 1983 at the business
school where basically we would like a
job I think people now are much more
proactive in thinking about what getting
that job will mean and what the
implications are down the line I really
do but I think when I look at my four
kids my oldest son is working on
basically software to put renewables on
the grid
my second son is an architecture student
who's trying to figure out how to use
the mimicry of nature to make better
spaces for people to live in my daughter
is working at an impact investor trying
to get good returns but also take into
account the what will mean for the world
if you make the investments and my
youngest son is claims to be about to
take the MCATs and he's working on
health policy for
a congressperson Congress person from
Southern California so my answer is I
don't think there's one answer I think
that as always you should do the things
that you love and are thrilled by but I
think that when you do them you should
do them with a perspective that there is
going to be that you're going to have a
lot of impact more than you think
and that the flip side of getting to go
to this incredibly elite institution I
know people hate hearing that everyone
would like to think that you know ah
shucks it's nothing special
it's very special people here get an
opportunity to have impact that's
absolutely disproportionate and I think
you should just be aware that when you
do you should take responsibility for
what's what you're causing and that that
is gonna I don't care what your job is
as long as you're doing that as long as
you're thinking it through as and your
you know your values are reasonable then
you will do good things and I think that
you know that is the responsibility of
getting all this special stuff which you
know I'm extremely grateful to have
gotten myself is a you know it is a
massive opportunity and with the massive
opportunity should come some sense of
responsibility that you don't just get
to do this for yourself that if you're
gonna get this chance special chance in
society that you should be thinking
about what that means for your
relationship to all the other people in
this society who didn't get that special
chance and and I think if you don't do
that I think it that would be a profound
mistake for someone will now open it up
to questions from the audience we've got
some microphones
hi Tucker Van Aken I'm an MBA one here
question on why impeachment why not
focus on the policy disagreements raise
those issues with the American people it
strikes me from a rhetoric perspective
that saying the man is an existential
threat he should be removed from office
is to no action impact this a bit
confusing and potentially dangerous so
thank you
so I've why impeachment well I do think
the man is an existential threat for
starters I do think that he's met the
standard for impeachment we're actually
gonna go through that I think in public
next week but I also think that there is
a question in our society really about
what we're doing and whether we're in
crisis so I look at the impeachment
question as are we in crisis and I
talked to a friend of mine and I thought
he said something so very large public
company and he said Tom I have a three
percent mortgage we have four percent
unemployment and the stock market is
irregular is it a record how are we in
crisis I said well the markets fluctuate
economies change around but if you look
what was going on politically if you
look at what's going on internationally
if you look at what's going on in terms
of the long term decisions for the
United States of America's we are in a
profound crisis that people are not
dealing with and that is the point of
impeachment is this I'm not sitting here
saying people who say to me you know I
was never gonna use this when they don't
like a tax bill this has nothing to do
with the tax bill we are in a profound
crisis and the question is when are
Americans going to be a are we going to
as a group realize this and understand
what's at stake so I actually think that
going after the individual bills all of
which I disagree with every single one
is the wrong way to do it that that is
something where you're really fighting
in DC I don't want to be fighting in DC
I don't think it's gonna be effective I
think it's a waste of time and money
what I want to be doing is I want to be
talking to people in Des Moines and
Schenectady and Cleveland and Dallas and
all across the country because those are
the people who I trust that's what I
think I keep saying the solution for us
is going to be a broader democracy not
to go back to the to Washington DC to
beg people to be more fun to build on
that question a little bit you you've
you've fuel that many questions about
you know whether or not this impeachment
campaign is setting up a run for
governor of California and I'm not gonna
repeat that question but you know
talking about whom you're fighting on
behalf of you know I I guess it was
curious what would you want potential
voters to know about you based on this
impeachment camp I mean yes that because
because you're the one fighting for them
well I don't think it's about me let's
start by saying this campaign is
supposed to be about everybody putting
their voice together the only thing I'd
really like people to understand is I
think that most of the people who
interview me ask me what my hidden
agenda is and there's an assumption in
there that no one would do something
because they just thought it was the
right thing to do that there has to be
something you know I remember when I
started on climate people would say to
me but you're doing this to make money
on your clean energy investments right
and I'd be like how does spending tens
of millions of dollars it has no
response make people richer it's like
but we actually made sure we made know
clean energy investments except through
our foundation so that we could just
take that off the table so when I think
about this impeachment my whole point
and this is we're trying to do what's
right because we think it's important
that's what I want people to think
that's all we want we want Americans to
think that there is a possibility to do
what's right and that is what we are
pushing for as hard as possible hi my
name is Todd ruler brand MBA one and I'm
curious to know so you know investing
all this money and technologies for
sustainable energy and trying to
influence policies to promote them but
people largely ignore the fact that if
you just got rid of fossil fuels today
you would be on having thousands of
people unemployed all of a sudden across
the US and largely this happened in the
coal industry and is definitely a factor
that led to the you know results of this
past election so to claim that we need
to get to sustainable energy as quickly
as possible but ignore this really large
fact of doing so could actually result
in electing even more insane potential
president president
what sort of your response to what are
you doing to to actually look at the
American workers and people that are
going to be voting in these elections to
ensure that if we do get to a
sustainable energy across the grid how
do we actually make sure that we're not
leaving other people behind so that is a
great question and before I give my
answer let me apologize for my answer
because I completely disagree with
almost everything you said so I'll but
we actually did a study on this so we
did a study what happens to employment
if we move to clean energy we can't move
to clean energy tomorrow it's always
going to be a question of pace and but
we did a study with Hank Paulson the
Republican secretary of the Treasury
under george w bush and mike bloomberg
who's been a democrat a republican and
is sort of an independent
guess to make sure that it wasn't a
partisan study and it basically showed
that in fact if we move to clean energy
it creates more jobs that we will have
higher paying jobs the United States
will grow faster and this isn't taking
into account the costs of having the
climate change and the kinds of
disasters that are going to cost the
United States three hundred billion
dollars this year but there is a true
there are a couple true points in what
you're saying that are absolutely
important politically and I agree with
one of them has to do with what are you
going to do with it's true there will be
more jobs and it's true the jobs will be
better paying but not for the same
people so the question is what are you
going to do my roommate my ex-roommate
lives in the poorest County in West
Virginia his brother-in-law is an
unemployed coal miner and his cousin is
an unemployed coal miner so I went down
to see him he has he's a retired career
army officer with some health problems
and I went down and he was telling me in
if you're a coal miner today you make 82
bucks an hour which in the poorest
County in West Virginia is an
unbelievable amount of money and the
next stop is probably 25 bucks an hour
so there is a recall mining is not like
the world's greatest job it's a really
well paid job with good benefits and
that's really what we're talking about
we're talking about what are we going to
do for the people in our society who
think look they're fifty thousand coal
miners in the United States of America
we could get it's a very very very very
small number of people but there's a
broader question here and that's what
Trump was referring to they're a group
of people in the United States of
America who do not live in Palo Alto
California they do not live in New York
City they do not live in the parts of
the country that are seeing real growth
they're not connected to the information
technology revolution they are not
connected to the positive aspects of
globalization and they can see the the
climate changing but for them that's the
LAT that is not the immediate problem
they're dealing with that's just
something that may put them out of work
so they feel completely scared by the
fact all the fact that the world is
changing that people in Palo Alto go
like woohoo just killed it on my latest
investment they're going like whoa the
world is changing and they just closed
the plant and there's only one plant or
they just closed the coal mine and now
what do we do now we're gonna get less
than half the dollars per hour that we
thought we were gonna get or though and
we were getting so the question to me is
not the macro question you asked but the
micro question what do we say to the
people in rural America or poor urban
America who are not connected to the
growth for whom the rapid pace of change
in our society is scary as anything and
that is what Trump was dealing with that
fear that uncertainty and that sense
that no one was listening and I would
say I would I think his answer was a
dishonest one and I think it was
absolutely he net he's we're not going
back to a lot of coal miners even if we
dug a ton more coal it's all mechanized
no one is going into a coal face with a
pick and shovel anymore period but he
but it was a perfect symbol for going
back to a time when being a hardworking
American who is working willing to go to
work every day and kill yourself you've
got a middle class job including in
rural America so the question is when we
talk to those people who are hardworking
and scared how are we actually not how
are we going to fake it how are we
actually gonna conclude them and to me
the question is twofold one is we need
to invest in the people of the United
States that means education training we
need to connect them to this world that
you guys are in right here in this
auditorium if you don't have broadband
in a community you could not compete in
the first world when I was in West
Virginia the roads were bad literally so
the question is if you're in that
community how can you possibly compete
in this world or be even be part of this
world and this includes rural California
if you're not connected real-time
it can't happen secondly if we're not
investing in those people we lose they
lose the country loses the idea that
we're gonna cut education training
health care food for poor kids from the
budget is insane it's not just it's
morally wrong but it's also crazy this
country will do well if Americans do
well we should be taking our money and
investing in those people so that they
think I'm going to be connected to the
world I'm going to be trained for the
world I'm gonna participate in this
world in the 21st century so that every
change doesn't actually push me further
away from what's going on in the real
world because if this if we were in
rural Wisconsin and there was one plant
in our town and that plant closed we
wouldn't know what to do either except
leave that's what's going on in this
world we need to invest and frankly
clean energy
it means rebuilding this country and it
actually means rebuilding this country
with millions of net new jobs we have to
do it it's a way for us in the short
term to get every community rural poor
urban people people in rural America we
have to do it everywhere it's good jobs
everywhere the question is what are the
jobs pay and who gets them I'll blessing
I'll say is this I was in Cleveland
talking to some inner-city ministers
about clean energy jobs and they were
excited I promise you at the idea that
we could bring thousands of jobs to
urban poor Cleveland with high
unemployment for their people in their
communities it's true in rural Wisconsin
too so when I hear it I know he's
talking the president was dealing with a
real emotional problem that is
absolutely felt in this country but he
wasn't giving a fair answer and the
answer I'm giving about invest in
Americans rebuild the country and
connect us all together is actually the
way that somebody living in a rural part
of this country can connect with you
guys in this room
or you could choose to live in a rural
part of California and still connect
with the fastest-growing most vibrant
countries companies in the world we are
almost out of time so I'm just gonna
take the final question from Yara we can
wrap up yes well officially according to
the clock uh-huh but the you know the
holidays are right around the corner and
I've read that you are known for
requiring guests at your annual
Christmas lunch to bring a poem to read
what's the best poem you've heard well I
would say there are some great American
poets right now the two that I would
recommend you if you're not reading your
poetry every night before bed Billy
Collins is hilarious and really profound
and mary oliver is fantastic and super
fun and Wow there if you read just those
two poets they are I promise you you
will laugh really hard and you will walk
away happier and with a sense of some
the world being a place where we can all
make a better we can have a positive
impact and that's what we're all too you
know the one thing I'd say to you guys
is look having a meaningful life is what
you should be going for that is what
will make you happy if you sit there and
think I'm having a positive impact I'm
having a meaningful life that is what
you will want when you're my age and so
when people say you're really trying to
do this to make more money I'm like no
selfishly I'm trying to have a positive
impact I'm not trying to say it's not
selfish but that's what I promise you
guys if you're doing that
you will find great joy in that and
that's what I've observed in myself and
all the people who I meet ladies and
gentlemen please think join me in
thanking time star
you
[Music]